HEADED IN THE RIGHT E
THAT IA BLE, ANDY  P.
JOING ME NOW CNN'SN I
WHIOWHN WAOULD THINK TD BE
ASKED BY MARIST COLLEGE.Y 'RHE ,
JUST 31%. ME,OH FAN OF
AVERAGES.
I DOLIT LOOKAT
HE TT
IS THE COUNTRY GOING ITHN  ACW
THE RIGHT ION. DURING TH, NG C%
NE17, 34LL THE WAY BACK
TO THE BEGINNINGTHE OBAMA RA% O
AMERICANSA WERE ON
THIS IS THT NUMBER IN
DECADEOV DECADE, IN FACT.
>> IT'S INTERESTING TO ME J
IB
WE SDDING JOBSET  CETERA,Y
NO 43%.
THAT'S A BIG
ISTISAN DIVIDE?
T
IS THE C IN TH
RIGHT DIRECT WRONG TRACK?
THRI
WHAT DO WEEE?
ES, WE'RIS
GOG  DIRECTION
S. 11% OF REPUBLICANS, N
COMPARE  TE WE WST
THE BIG NUE WE TAKAY
IS THE INDENTO NOW
AND DEMOCRAT 73, MUCH HIGHER RES
NE THA REPUBLI THIELL IS
INUANDIDATE NEEDS TO GOING WE
HIT IN TER
EO TO GET RE-ELECT
>> I THINK THI RATHEPOE ESSENTI
E Y HOW GOOD IS s NUMBER FOR JO
TIAL REELECTIONSEINCUMBENT PARTC
RIGHT DIERRIGHT K
42%.
VERY, VERY CE TOBIDEN IS RIGHT.
YOU HAVE A RIGHT TRACK DIR
ONLY AROUN25%.
S MUCH CLOSER TO WHERE RUMP WAS
WAS IN T
GHLO
E GHACMBER, Y 43% THAT BIDEN HA
TO WHAT NORMALLY I
PARTIES ED .
>> THERE ARE OTHER NUMBEN
THIS MT SHOW PEOPLE HAVE HISTORL
POSITI V EVEN SE NUMBERS L
SOMEWHAT NEGATIVE.
DID SE UP THT WAY?.
ESSEIAORMALLY THE
ONG TRACNUMBERBAD.THE SAME WITH.
THE HATE CONGR
PARED TOA DISAIT'S SIGNIFICANTLG
INDUSTRATION.
YOU HAVE TO AGAIGOCK TO F 2009 O
THES30s.W
E POORT
AS POOR ASY WERE BEFORH  GH MORE
CERTNL POINTY
>>E E HAT HEY,S NOT AS
WAS BEFORE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THA
>> THANK YOU
>> HAVING A CHKL YOU PUT IT.
>>> LET'S LOOK AT ALL ESE
NUMBERWIANALYS
RYAN WHAT DO YOIN
NUERN THAT REYOU'REK BE VERY HA.
E  Y KNOW, THINGS SEAVE TURNED
WANTED IN TERM PEOPLE BEING
INATED, BUT TH
OUT OF HIS HANDS, RI
E THERWHO JUST AG GS >>
PEOPLEEI PEOPLE ON THEIG
PART.
I THINK IF YOU'RE JOE BIDEN,
THINK THIS MAKES YOU VER
AND PEOPLE ARETARTINL LITTLEE I
THONOMY AND WI
GETTING BACKETO NORL Y R JOE
NUMBERS RE NOT GOING
WE'RE ALL LOCKED AT HOMEHE DYINA
S AT 10%.
>> THAT RT DIDE, WOW.ISE THBLICD
>>MY I
PEOPLE T THE WIMPROVEMENNING.AR
BECAIT WHITE HOUSE DESPITE
CLEARLY IMPROVED FRO THAT, LE,TE
WERE BS PRESIDENT.
>> DON'T YOU THINKOUGH --
CAN YOU
CLIMATE?
THAT'S PIT
POLARIZATION.
DOOW THAN GET
HIGHER THAN THAT.
>> L SO THAT POINT.
F OBJECTIVELY YOU LOOK AT ON
GOG  DIRECTION, ETTER, BING THA
BECAUSENTIALLY DRESSIKNOW, OWSAS
BECOME A SORT OF RELIGOR
LET'S LI
>> POLITICS IS BECOMING RELIGION
THAT POLITS IS
SPORT AND ENTERTAINMENTIN OUR U
EVPOLITICAL. AUGE AND IT'S
CAUSED US TO MAKE D DECISIONRI
OTHEAS
WELL.SO IT'S DEEPLY.
>> I DEEBLING.
ITK THATE THING
WHEN YOU TREAT PS THAT WAY
WHEN I AND
DEATIT'S ANOTHER THING WHEN IT
'S WHA
WE'VE SEEN THIS MOOBVIOUSLY IN F
POLARIZATION FUITE
BUWITH COVS WE SAW THA ACTUALLY
IN PEOPLNG AHE
NGER TO ACTUALLY DIE IN
FU THEIR POLITICAL
BEEFILLING IR HEADS I
AND SAY, THEE I ALIGN  T
M GOIN ITH IIS
CEETHINGIKOW OUT HINGS HAVEOTEA.
MAPOISSU
YOU' TBELIEVE INUBLICAN
WEMAS,DEMO YEL
WHEN THE SCIECPOLITICIZED DURINI
T ,
WAD .THING IW POLITICA
'S FIRST PERSON TO
POINT THIS OUT.
OTHERS HAVE POIND TH
THE TRS AMERANBECOME LESS RELIG
OUVEATL THAT VACUUAND PO A LOT E
OU SPEND A LOT
OF TE
THE CULTURW CIZED IN SOME WAY.
WHO IDEOPLE WHO A
RELIGIOUS, THEY HAVENSD
IEFS ARE IN SO THERE IS VERYE TT
TERMS OF FAI